اضافه الى احياء مدمره فكل المباني
الموجوده على هذا الطريق متصدعه بالكامل
لا تصلح للسكن وهناك مخاوف من انهيارات
جزئيه او كليه لا قدر الله في حال وجود
هزات ارتداديه
لذلك السلطات التركيه تمنع منعا باتا
الدخول الى هذه المباني نظرا لخطوره
الموقف وخشيه تعرض من يدخل الى هذه
المباني الى اضرار لا قدر الله في حال
الوصول او في حال حدوث هزات ارتداديه لذلك
تم الاخلاق كل سكان هذه المباني من هذه
المنطقه وتم اجلاؤهم الى مراكز ايواء مؤقت
لحين انقشاع او لحين التحقق من جاهزيه هذه
المباني
السكن طبعا يعني حقيقه الدمار كان كبير
جدا في هذه الولايه يعني في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا نوردا لان اليوم الاول الذي شهد
حدوث الزلزال اي يوم الاثنين الماضي وبعد
حوالي ربع ساعه من حدوث الزلزال الاول في
تمام الساعه الرابعه وسبعه عشره والذي كان
مركزه كهرمان مرعش بعد ربع ساعه من هذا
التوقيت حدثت هزه ارتداديه قويه جدا هنا
في هذه المدينه كانت قوتها 6.6 بلغت شدتها
6.6
ساهمت
بزياده الاضرار التي خلفها الزلزال الاول
الكبير ومن ثم جاء بعد تسع ساعات الزلزال
الثاني الذي ايضا كان مركزه كهرمان مرعش
وادى وادى الانهيار مباني اضافيه طبعا
الهزات الارتداديه التي تلت هذا هذه
الزلازل
الكبيره ايضا ساهمت في تازيم الوضع وفي
انهيارات اضافيه وهذا ما عقد من مهمه رجال
الانقاذ خصوصا ان الساعات الاولى التي
كانت او التي شهدت حدوث الزلزال ادت الى
تعطل الطريق السريع ساطلب من زميلي المصور
ان يرصد هناك في اعلى الجبال المطله على
نورداف